hello I'm Devin their company I'm
manager of calculus Roger Bertram and
the softener I speak about asymptotic
computation but it's just a simple way
of getting approximate formulae for
several mathematical problems whether
you are a mathematician or computer
scientists or verses you will find this
talk enjoyable and easy heliports in
thank you
okay hello everyone I'm Devin Eric
Kapadia and I'm the manager of Calca
Sajha Brett Wolfram and I'm speaking
about a rather large project team
project which we welcome to the last
couple of years
that's an asymptotic competition and I
do appreciate you all showing up over
here at 4 o'clock and me afternoon on
the last day of a conference I really do
appreciate so thank you very much for
being here and well that sounds like a
really technical area but in fact the
goal of asymptotic competition is very
simple given a problem a function a
sequence a differential equation a
difference equation integral whatever
find a simple approximate formula for
that problem and of course when you have
an approximate formula then you lose
something or he loses that you can't
wander too far away from point that's
where the word asymptote comes from so
we work at a point were close to it get
a nice formula and that's it and well
the next 20 minutes or so I'd like to
give you a thorough introduction to what
we've done so I'm going to begin with
Sterling's formula which i think is
where asymptotic really began in 18th
century a very well known formula and
then talk about the asymptotic function
which is the main new function super
function for version 12.1 and once
they've got that set up then we talk
about integrals integral transform
differential equations and I assume
tortex for them that's continuous
calculus when that's done I'll switch
gears and talk about discrete
asymptotics of sequences using a
discrete asymptotic function so that's
new functions we go to asymptotic for
continuous discrete asymptotic for
sequences and then once I've got that
set up I'll talk about how you can apply
to some product summation transform
difference equations and last but not
the least a vast area of asymptotics is
the asymptotes of algebraic equations
and transfer equations and I'll try and
cover that as well so that's the goal
for the stock to try and cover that area
of asymptotic computation so let's begin
with Sterling's formula so it's not
university well-known but what's now
called Sterling's formula actually due
to abraham de moivre so de Moura was
quite
fantastic mathematician and in fact he
knew Isaac Newton and Newton would often
say that go to tomorrow he knows more
about these things than I do so but de
Muro made his living by tutoring and
gambling and in 1730 he discovered a
formula for approximating the factorial
it looked pretty good but he was missing
a constant somewhere and that constant
square root of 2 pi which is co a year
and a few months later his friend James
Stirling told him that that
consciousness could of 2 pi and that's
what became Sterling's formula so
Sterling's formula was rediscovered by
de Moura and the main part in
asymptotics he who needs the constant
gets the fame okay so we see today that
these formulae really require you to
know some constant and but if I say over
your asymptote equivalent of X factorial
is that Stirling formula then all that
means that the factorial has a ratio of
1 to that in the limit as we go to
infinity that's all that there is so we
have two new functions asymptotic and
discrete asymptotic which compute the
estimate of approximately four function
sequences and operators in the most
general sense so that's the goal for
this talk so let's begin with asymptotic
so simple example take the sine function
work near zero we all know from high
school almost that sine X is
approximately equal to X as long as
you're close to zero and that's the
linear approximation to sign now you
might want more term you see I need more
accuracy then you have got this option
called series term goal for asymptotics
which sometimes you can say goes to 12
over here and you get back a certain
better approximation and that
approximation is pretty good as you can
see over here so let me just go down and
there you go okay so that's a much nicer
proximation and in fact I think that
this kind of formula is a much better
way of doing calculus and other teach
calculus quite a lot it's a much nicer
way of doing calculus then working with
circles and trigonometric functions
because you can just differentiate over
you and see that the
the sine X is cosine X etc so I think
that the asymptotic viewpoint actually
dominates all of calculus although we
don't know it and we know call it that
okay so just to prove that point or a
year I'm going to show you a gallery of
function asymptotic so I have a
polynomial a rational function a trig
function the airy function a trig
function again Paloma trig and the prime
PI function from number theory so all
these functions have got nice
asymptotics there you see so in each
case the red curve is the actual
function the blue dotted curve is the
asymptotic so the first polynomial is
asymptotic to X cube the second rational
function asymptotes to one way as you
can see and sine X like asymptotes to X
etc so the point is that this kind of
asymptotic impersonation you do all the
time and you do calculus and it's really
what drives the whole of calculus 1 for
example ok so once you understand what
asymptotic is the question is why is
it's so important and why did we give
this strange name asymptotic I had lots
of almost objection how dit can call
something asymptotic well the reason is
that we want asymptotic to be like N in
Mathematica where you row n of integrate
you get n integrate to n of some we get
n some do n of D circuit nd saw etc so
now I can actually plunge into calculus
so here is an inactive integral and if
you don't know secret of that why it's
inactive just mouse over it you see it's
inactive integrate I have disabled
integrate and this example actually is
from a book by on advanced calculus by
woods which Fineman used to study
calculus right it took up that book
that's example he probably studied his
famous trick of differentiating an
integral sign and I put into asymptotic
and I said finally asymptotic for me and
about 0.2 seconds at game I came back
the answered exact answer now of course
you could use asymptotes integrate for
same thing
but the main point is that in this case
this answer is not just approximate it
actually is exact and the question is
why is exact
well that's the asymptotics is good
because it gives you insights into why
things are what they are so what you see
away if you do see the expansion then
that and the two log eighth term is the
one that's actually you know doing all
the work the other terms are harmonics
and they just die out in no time at all
so all the cosine terms over you're a
harmonic but over the into 0 to PI they
all give you 0 so in fact the asymptotic
answer is the exact answer now if you
look at woods it takes one and a half
days to give the answer and here we get
back in point two seconds with no work
at all I didn't know that in advance
so that's integrals that's about half of
calculus one done now on to integral
transforms so you got lots of integrals
so we got Fourier transform Laplace
transform huncle transform Mellon
transformed radon transform every two
days someone says you're the neutron or
leg wants a D transform so we cannot
keep on having asymptotic this
asymptotic that so we need one super
function in which you can throw what you
like it'll do the right thing so over
here you have a function which is
obviously has Laplace transform it's
decaying very very fast so I throw into
asymptotic why the inactive
well I must disable it because it's
going to take a long long time probably
tell me that we cannot do the Laplace
transform and even a single term over
here you actually get back a pretty good
asymptotic approximation so my point is
that you will always be able to get good
approximations using the asymptotic
method as long as things are kind of
reasonable oh yeah fine
okay sorry yester minute okay
so back to integral transforms and so
you see over you have to actually have a
quite a nice answer with almost no
effort on your hand the difficult
problem is how do you compute inverse
Laplace transforms now that's a big area
we're just getting into it but you see
over here that we actually can get a
very nice asymptotic inverse Laplace
transform in many good cases so you can
do Fourier inverse Fourier Laplace
inverse Laplace what you like using the
asymptotic function okay so now on to
differential equations so here's a
differential equation looks pretty
simple but there's an e raise to X in it
so that's a non rational coefficient
it's impossible to solve that at least
as far as I know with current
functionality so you see a way that if
we divide by the X cube you actually
have a singularity at 0 so that's the
complex plot showing that over here and
the main point is that that single arity
actually is an irregular singularity so
it's not an ordinary point it's not a
regular single point it's an irregular
singular point but the same technique
that works for rational functions also
works for exponential function then
these singularities and you get back a
nice solution like you would in a course
on differential equations at college
level so you can do asymptotics of lots
of things over here and you get back
nice answers simply by using all these
tricks of approximation ok so now I can
go on to the discrete side of things and
discrete asymptotic so begin simple with
the Stirling formula the Stirling
formulas just what I saw early on it's e
to the minus n n to the n plus 1/2 times
square root of 2pi but of course you can
go much further than that so here's a
nice table of things of discrete
asymptotics
I've done a lot to collect them but if
you are experienced area I'm not an
expert in this area really if you work a
lot of sequences you know something let
me know okay but on the Left we have a
sequence n factorial Fibonacci harmonic
number prime zeta binomial Pokemon Euler
and partition and though the right are
the asymptotics for those sequences so
now we are into sequence world and you
can do the same kind of trick that we
done early on for this sorry
well it's not it's continuous so prime
is that that's the problem okay here's
the problem we have got two worlds
they've got a continuous world a
discrete world in the continuous world
you can be where you like in the complex
plane the discrete world you can go to
infinity if you really ambitious go to
negative infinity and you're done in the
continuous world everyone loves
continuous special functions we got a
coleg and other people real experts in
the discrete world things get really
really sparse and people might spend a
whole lifetime trying to get one more
term of the sum number theory function
so I admit we are kind of limited over
here if you know what to do over here
let us know okay but I think that's a
nice table which shows how powerful is
asymptotic formula are okay so now I can
move on from there
and having set it up talked about sums
and products so for version twelve point
we have this new functional asymptotic
sum which does asymptotic sums but then
a long time ago 2007 probably I
developed this so-called divergent
series functionality and I wrote a blog
post called the ABCD of divergent series
which is surprisingly popular even today
I get emails like every few months
saying I like that blog post so the
question is can we do asymptotics of
divergent series in a sense that's the
only place where you want to do
asymptotics because you don't have a
good convergence crichton at all
so here what you have is a divergent
some pretty messy one I'm saying Borah
regulation which is a kind of regulation
and you get back a nice simple answer
via if we didn't do that you might get a
Bessel function or something like that
but this answers actually pretty good
for most purposes yes you get a Bessel
answer but but the thing is that what we
do is we kind of we cut into the
implementation frankly and at the point
were you actually doing all the hard
work of summing or integrating whatever
we do the regular regularization kind of
stuff so in many cases that you will
agree but their exams will be their lot
so this expands the whole thing out and
at the least you get back a nice
approximation compared to having Bessel
K which is a kind of pretty horrible
function to work with you get back this
nice power kind of thing or gamma
chillness keys yeah okay so one new kid
on the block for volume 12.1 is
asymptotic product and you see to a year
this is actually based on a paper by
Garrett Birkhoff and it's a very nice
example because the point is you can do
the asymptotics but it's almost
impossible to determine the constant to
area so when you try to determine the
constant to here it's hard to get
exactly and you can see where the that
the input is exact but the output is in
exact and that's the new philosophy that
we're gonna allow this kind of situation
where we don't have a real good idea
what the constant is but you can think
of this approximation as being an
approximation of a real constant and the
approximation is pretty good over here
okay so let me scroll down a little bit
and show you and you see approximation
is pretty good at even 80 terms
okay so now I go on beyond this and yes
there is so now all our symbolic
functions from now on we'll have numerix
options working position accuracy goal
not that I know to work with them but
yeah okay mean so we really we are
trying to have one in striving to
different functions we'll have one
function which allows you this freedom
so by default to make good choice so we
say working position goes to automatic
and we can do what we like or you tell
us and we'll do it for you okay
right but that's a good question yeah so
okay so let me go on now to summation
transform so you know when I did my PhD
a long time ago I took try did not bring
community tricks and when I was kind of
depressed I would tell myself at least
we don't do comedy tricks for a PhD you
know so for a long time I had this kind
of feeling that that's not an
interesting subject but last year Raja
government's and who's actually driving
our project showed me a wonderful book
it's called analytic combinatorics by
Robert Sedgwick and Philippe freshly
it's only hundred pages long and it's
free on the web so I started the book
and the idea is this it you have a
sequence let's see many files generating
function let's say by some method but
you don't know sequence and a generating
function like a like a clothes line on
which you hang the sequence and the pegs
of that sequence of the clothes line are
the powers of Z over here in that
expansion so generating function is what
encodes all the information about
sequence although you may not know
sequence itself so here's an example
from their book it's 1 over 2 minus e
raise to Z and you work out a few terms
it looks pretty dreadful and absolutely
hopeless the fraction seemed to grow
quite a lot but discrete asymptotic will
do the following it will go in to the
generating function look at the
singularities in the complex plane keep
in mind you're working with the integers
but we do a single IT analysis
give the leading term and you get back
this really nice asymptotic for the
sequence and that asymptotic actually
gives you back a wonderfully accurate
professor okay so the point or year is
that you can always get nice answers by
doing discrete asymptotic a little push
down a little bit and you see over here
that the asymptotic is actually going to
give you a pretty good approximation for
the actual sequence oh I didn't see that
it's okay
so that's generating function summations
they can do z-transform inverse
z-transform furious sequence transfer
what he like the discrete Anatoly tonic
okay so on to the next theme which is
difference equations so the nice story
behind this so in 1960 actually Andrey
Kolmogorov the famous Russian
mathematician organized seminar and this
seminar had a purpose the purpose was to
show that a schoolbook multiplication
which we'll learn high school is the
most optimal way of multiplying two
numbers and he he's a big man
organized seminar and a week later a
student in that seminar twenty or unless
we can super tell him he was wrong and
in fact found what was one of the first
divide and conquer algorithms for
multiplication and you would think that
Calma Grove was very annoyed with him he
did nothing of that sort he said he
canceled the seminar wrote a paper and
consumers name without letting him know
and publicize the work everywhere so
that's kind of so multiplication which I
believe we have in Mathematica even now
is that correct mark sorry yeah so it's
Tim Cook and we have some multiplication
kind of algorithm by D but the main
point is that you save one
multiplication sort of four by doing
card Suba so instead of four at every
step you have three multiplications and
that reduces complexity from n square to
n raised to power one point five eight
and that was the great achievement of
karatsuba
and you can see over here that we get
back this beautiful asymptotic formula
for this rather wonderful approximation
and if you look at the graph below you
see that in fact we have a plot over
here which shows the color Suba and the
schoolbook multiplication so initially
schoolbook seems to be better but very
quickly karatsuba takes a much smaller
number of steps okay so that's
difference equations and now on to
algebra so if we have a very nice
function called asymptotic solve which
can do both algebraic transfer equations
now this particular problem or here is
the Kepler equation and that's the
famous problem so you can do an
approximation you can see approximate is
really good and I could spend some more
time on this but my main point is that
one good thing about our team I'd say
generally become a department is that we
are pretty good documentation so this
example here is more or less stolen from
each i's documentation of asymptotic
solve so these days giving a talk with
no problem at all good documentation
copy/paste and you're done okay
add some fluff to it and you okay so I
invite you to look at this wonderful
page that it is written for asymptotic
solve and you will get lots of examples
for transcendental equations
algebraically etc you know algebraic
geometry is an old subject and every
century they go up in dimension by one
so in the early centuries heading curves
then surfaces now there are three folds
if you come back after one century to
attend the conference over here they'll
be talking about four folds so that's a
vast area but we are trying to capture
it with asymptotics but I think that
what we have is really a nice mix of
functionality for all kinds of
asymptotics so I my main point is that
we really want to drive this asymptotic
computation to its you know very limit
and in doing so I just want to make sure
that we try and get into every barrier
then try and cross it as easily as
possible
but that's about all I had to say I'm
really running out of time but my main
point is that this asymptotic
computation is like a third more of
computing in addition to the you got
symbolic computation a numeric
computation would keep in mind they have
had 30 years and the world's best
developers we had two years so please
forgive us if you've got some things not
working right yet we will get them
working soon the second point is that
going forward we'll continue develop
continued fraction cetera but for now I
think we have reached a very good
stopping point and I hope you think that
this asymptotic competition really is
the new mode of mathematical computing
so stop oh yeah thank you very much
[Applause]